[Music]
after avengers end game the superhero
troop from the marvel cinematic universe
defeated the fiercest and most powerful
enemy so it seems that they are now
equal to everything that is still hiding
in the depths of the universe
but what if they would face the
counterpart from the dc extended
universe the justice league
okay well at the box office you wouldn't
even call the fight there the team
surrounding superman was basically
overrun by the mcu
today however we'd rather focus on a
real fight to keep it fair we're also of
course limiting the marvel heroes to
just six
namely captain america iron man thor
hulk captain marvel
and black panther dc's heroes are set
with batman
superman the flash aquaman wonder woman
and cyborg
in this video we have them face off
against each other in epic battles and
you get to decide who would win the team
matchup by the end
we refer to abilities and techniques
that play a role in the movies and will
leave the comics out of evaluation
we are confident that the video will
provide you with plenty to talk about
the battles are as we subjectively
imagined them depending on how you
interpret something
there can certainly be 14 million 605
different
endings what better match-up to start
with than the hatch of the squad iron
man vs batman
tony stark against bruce wayne
billionaire against billionaire men and
armor against battle of the night
the powers are quickly explained tony's
abilities are
all within his suit in addition to
various projectiles he
also has the energy burst from his hand
and feet of course
batman is different he gets his strength
mainly from his muscle power and he's a
gifted one-on-one fighter
in the league of shadows he has also
learned how to use targeted diversions
in order to confuse his opponents and
thus take advantage of the given terrain
their flaws are pretty much the same
they are after all only human and just
as vulnerable as anyone else
though it can be said that ironman still
has better protection thanks to his
armor suit
batman's advantage is that tony has to
fight him on the ground since he can't
fly by himself
even though he will initially be more
clumsy dodging the projectile sooner or
later he will manage to force iron man
into close combat
conceivable would be that he uses his
rope gun to pull the man in the armor
towards him or to carry himself towards
him
however as the bat will discover to his
regret ironman's armor is beyond
flexible and the individual parts would
simply renew themselves
through nanotechnology in case of doubt
despite tony's arrogance he likely
wouldn't just end up taking batman's
life
rather he'd incapacitate him as soon as
the opportunity arose he would either
imprison him
in one of his suits or he would lock him
up in the same prison he developed for
hulk in the age of ultron
or rather the prison would transport
itself to him
this would leave batman out of the game
and allow iron man to help his
colleagues
when you think of brute muscle strength
there's one hero you can't help but
think of
and that's the hulk after a failed
experiment with gamma rays dr bros
banner develops an alter ego
the hulk he finds it difficult to
control him particularly when he gets
into stressful situations
luckily in this fight he will not need
to do that as he will need all his
strength
after all the battle is set against
aquaman the king of atlantis can unleash
all his power especially in the sea
there he can not only use poseidon
strident but he also swims faster than
an airplane and has the ability to
command
aquatic animals so it's pure destructive
power against the might over natural
forces
aquaman is smart enough not to look for
a fight on land but luckily he doesn't
have to do so
provoking the green monster is quite
enough to make it chase him in fact the
biggest weakness of the hulk is that in
a fight he utterly loses control and
stops thinking
once near the water or in the sea it'll
be easy to defeat banner
he can just keep him underwater until he
loses consciousness it's a fight even
the hulk can't win
his only hope may be to drag out the
fight until someone of his fellow
fighters has the upper hand to rush to
his aid
in the 101 he'll definitely draw the
short straw so that aquaman will
quickly be able to join in another fight
in the third fight we come to the battle
of the gods thor
the god of thunder against wonder woman
the demi-goddess and daughter of
hippolyta and
zeus regarding the powers thor can not
only make lightning rain from the sky
thanks to mjolnir he has also the
ability to fly he is superhumanly strong
and as we saw in infinity war even the
energy of a dying star
can't kill him but at least it can knock
him out
with stormbreaker he's got a weapon that
can seemingly cut through anything
and can even take down thanos if you aim
for the head that is
even if he seems invincible he can be
knocked unconscious in close combat as
we've seen many times in the movies
as previously mentioned diana prince
alias wonder woman is a demi goddess
she is super humanly fast and powerful
and with the lasso of truth she can hold
opponents and draw
any secret out of them with it she can
even create hallucinations she can also
use her bracelets to unleash energy
blasts that brings down enemies
in addition she owns an eagle shield
which is difficult to cut through
even for thor and the sword of athena
which can even wound superman
as a demi goddess she's tough but not
invulnerable it surely doesn't matter
where the battle will be fought
as it will be fierce and close one the
weapons are both
equally strong so it will come down to
who will bring the greater fighting
skill to the battle
this is where we see thor clearly ahead
due to his experience even though his
cockiness may stand in his way
however as soon as wonder woman lands
her first critical hits against him
he'll start to take the fight seriously
even if her armor is not pierced
mjolnir's blows and the lighting
striking down on her will sooner or
later bring her down
who knows perhaps even in time for him
to rush to hulk's aid
the beginning of the second half is made
by captain america against the half
robot cyborg who was created from a
mother
box the abilities are clear captain
america is not only very strong but also
enduring fast
and incredibly tough cyborg on the other
hand has
all sorts of weapons and can hack into
any software the advantage in this fight
will clearly be that steve rogers
doesn't need to rely on any technical
devices
all he needs are his muscles and his
shield even if cyborgs fires all weapons
in him he can deflect him easily with
his vibranium shield
once he gets close enough to the half
machine the ladder won't stand a chance
and captain america will take him apart
by any means necessary this might be one
of the shortest fights in this matchup
and the winner will no doubt be captain
america
he'll also be needed at one front or the
other for sure
as the penultimate combat we present
black panther against the flash
as in the previous one the powers are
clearly distributed the king of wakanda
relies mainly on his physical abilities
and his vibranium modified suit
while the flash well he's the fastest
superhero there is and it's exactly
strength that will tip the scales here
with mere muscle power the flash is no
match for anybody probably the only
person who can keep up with his speed is
captain marvel
so black panther can try to fight back
as much as he wants
sooner or later the flash will beat him
with his speed
we for our part predicted to happen
sooner than later that's also important
since things aren't going very well for
the dc heroes in
the other fights and so he might be able
to turn the tables
the biggest fight comes of course at the
end if you look at the mcu there are
probably only two characters who can
come close to taking on this son of
krypton
the man of steel namely thor and captain
marvel however since the god of thunder
is already embroiled in battle with
another goddess carol danvers will have
to take over this round
danvers got her pals directly from the
tesseract in the explosion her dna fuses
with that of the stone thus not only can
she
fly at the speed of light but she has
extra stamina superhuman strength
and it seems hard to even scratch her
her only vulnerability that we can
determine up to this point is probably
that she has no protection against
magic moving on to superman the man of
steel draws his power directly from our
sun
there seems to be no limit to what he
can do he's very fast and can fire a
heatray from his eyes
he also has superhuman sense of hearing
and can detect the smallest of things
the latter two however should not be of
much importance in this fictional battle
his only weakness but a serious one is
the mineral from his home planet the
kryptonite
this not only makes him vulnerable but
can also kill him as we saw in batman
versus superman
it is imaginable that both would move
their fight into space as it would
probably take a toll on the earth as we
know it
denver's only chance to gain the upper
hand is to lure superman away from the
sun to the point where his powers are
dwindling away
having the speed advantage she should
use it before going into close combat
the heat ray in her energy ray should
neutralize each other in terms of power
since she fires a superpower from her
hands she can use it more effectively
if she can get superman to chase her
until he is far enough away from the sun
she should go into a one-on-one mr ken
will still be very strong
so it'll be most likely a tough fight
but it will be one in which danvers
comes out on top without kryptonite
she's unlikely to be able to take him
out
but she'll be capable of knocking him
unconscious to rejoin the match up on
earth
as we know from the movie superman tends
to react emotionally at times so if she
provokes him enough
he will surely pursue her and fall into
the trap
in summary it stands four to two in
favor of the heroes from the mcu
the only question is what will they do
against the flash speed
or whether it is enough to turn the
fight around we don't think so and with
the arrival of captain marvel at the
latest
he'll be forced to give up and the
heroes around iron man and captain
america will win
in the end they are more powerful and
have the more effective abilities
but now it's your turn how much did you
like the matchup
do you agree with us on the fights or do
we overestimate the power of the
individual heroes at one point or
another
let us know your answer in the comments
of course we also hope you enjoyed our
video give us a thumbs up if you did
see you next time
[Music]
you